[Music]
when Donald Trump ran for president he
promised to institute a 100 day action
plan to make America great again as a
hundred day mark approaches how's he
doing
reason presents the three worst and the
three best achievements of President
Trump's first 100 days Bing Bing Bing we
will be able to immediately repeal and
replace Obamacare along with his pledge
to build a wall on the southern border
and deport illegal immigrants on mass
Trump's campaign was all about ramming
through the repeal and replace Obamacare
Act which would have cut red tape gotten
rid of the individual mandate and
created a true marketplace for medical
insurance instead thanks to the
president's own lack of savvy and GOP
dithering
it didn't even get a proper vote in
Congress Bing Bing Bing president Trump
has just ordered a military strike on
Syria the one action for which President
Trump has received bipartisan praise was
the bombing of a Syrian government
airbase to protest the alleged use of
chemical weapons by the Assad regime
even opposition leaders such as Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer signed on to a
starkly humanitarian intervention that
served no greater purpose than rallying
voters here in America being being being
the president has issued two executive
decrees calling for a moratorium on
travel from several majority Muslim
countries and the suspension of
America's refugee program both have been
stayed by federal courts and it remains
unclear if either will ever become the
law of the land we only want to admit
those into our country who will support
our country regardless its anti-american
to effectively establish a religious
test for travelers and migrants here and
it also undermines attempts to reach out
to the vast majority of Muslims who are
the primary targets of Islamic
fundamentalism being Bing Bing judge
Neil Gorsuch the nomination of an
intellectually powerful and highly
respected jurist to replace the late
Antonin Scalia on the Supreme Court
demonstrated that President Trump isn't
the flake that many critics figured him
to be so was that a surprise was it Neel
Gorsuch might not be libertarian but he
is in the estimation of Georgetown law
is Randy Barnett a serious thinker who
believes that government power is and
should be limited being being being
there's no question that Trump is
take some terrible cabinet members
Attorney General Jeff Sessions has
openly talked about ramping up the war
on pot in states where it's legal for
instance good people don't smoke
marijuana he also defends asset
forfeiture abuse and is hinted at
reviving federal porn prosecutions as
well but picks such as GTI at the
Federal Communications Commission
Scott Gottlieb at the Food and Drug
Administration and Scott Pruitt at the
Environmental Protection Agency are
serious D regulators who are already
starting to prune back regulations that
accomplished little but cost taxpayers
and innovators lots of time money and
resources being being being every new
president enters office thinking he can
direct the course of human history by
his pen or in the case of Trump his
Twitter feed for all his bluster and
lack of self-awareness Trump is also
learning that the world is more
complicated than he reckoned he's pushed
back deadlines for all sorts of projects
from funding for his stupid and useless
immigration wall to a timeline for tax
reform which shows that he's at least
living in the real world to the extent
he realizes that his best path forward
is in cutting economic regulation rather
than vilifying immigrant renegotiating
trade deals and starting new wars
he'll not only be a better president
he'll create a better America too for
reason i'm nicolas ting
[Music]